a subject for today
a better day is coming genesis chapter
12 reading from verse one
thank you very much this afternoon at
four o'clock we have our prayer for the
sick
it will be right here right here we've
been asking you to make some spiritual
preparations
one if you sinned against someone find
that person and say you are sorry
god requires that whether you're sick or
you're healthy as
a horse to if someone has wronged you
we've all been wronged find that person
tell the person here's what you did
here's how it injured me
but i forgive you i forgive you
fully and freely no grudges and i pray
god bless you
and three let's confess our sins
whatever they are we're committing
put them away by the grace of god and
seek his power to commit them no more
and of course some of us are fasting
until after the service
this afternoon and remember uh beginning
on sunday nine o'clock in the morning
until five
and then monday through wednesday one to
eight i will have the great joy of
meeting one-to-one with god's people
i believe the location is the university
church am i right okay i'm not sure what
room but
you one or three university
church it's now uh eight minutes to
twelve so i have to move quickly
without seeming to be hasty let's bow
our heads
our father in heaven as we prepare for
the message
i ask you in the name of jesus to be
with me
because of my heavy responsibility
lord from my heart i lay my glory in the
dust where it belongs
i humble myself before you because a
divine work cannot be done by an
unaided human being i pray that you'd
grant me the words father and i pray
this earnestly
because one wrong word can ruin the
message
i pray also for those who have come lord
i ask you to soften their hearts
by applying again the blood of christ
and the prick of the holy spirit that
the words preached
may be the words received that your name
may be glorified in the lives of your
people
as their lives are changed i pray in
jesus name
amen a subject for today a better day
is coming genesis chapter 12
reading from verse one one of my
favorite passages
it is a key bible passage
genesis 12 reading from verse one
now the lord has said unto abram get
thee out of thy country
and from thy kindred and from thy
father's house unto a land that i will
show thee
and i will make of thee a great nation
and i will bless thee and make thy name
great and thou
shalt be a blessing and i will bless
them that bless thee and curse him that
curseth thee
and in thee shall all families
of the earth be blessed
in this promise is the promise
of a seed how else could abraham be a
great nation
without seed now at every step in a
man's relationship with
god or a woman god tests that person
abraham was tested very early
in genesis chapter 11 verse 20 we read
and abraham and cereal was barren she
had no
child we know from genesis 11
30 that abraham's wife could not
have children now he knows that
and it is in the context of the
barrenness of his wife
that the words ring in his ear and i
will make of thee
a great nation
no wonder the just shall live how
only faith can permit a man not to
collapse under the weight of that
seeming contradiction
and impossibility my wife cannot
have children and i am supposed to
believe
that i will make of thee a great nation
i cannot afford school fees for my
children
and i'm supposed to believe bring you
all the tithe into the storehouse
i cannot find a job here's one offered
to me with a high pay
requiring me to work on saturday and i'm
supposed to believe remember the sabbath
day
to keep it holy
we must trust the word of god absolutely
sometimes when i pray to god i tell god
very strange things let me let you in on
one of them
don't spread it around i said lord
even if i were to go to hell
before the flames consumed me
my last words would be to those standing
on the walls of the holy city
trust god believe his word
trust god believe his words
those will be my last words because i
have seen
god's word is and the word absolutely is
too weak but it's all i have
it is absolutely
trustworthy
so abraham had in his breast this
promise of a seed
not only of a seed but when god called
him
to go into this strange land he
understood he would receive the land
let's go to verse 7.
revelation 12 not revelation genesis 12
reading verse 7
and the lord appeared unto abram and
said unto thy seed
will i give this land and there build it
here an altar unto the lord who appeared
unto him
until thy seed will i give this land now
the suggestion in that verse is it was
to be given to the seed
and not to abram but that's not true
let's go to chapter 13 of genesis
let's read verse 14. as we continue a
better day is coming it's 3 minutes to
12.
you understand i need a little time to
preach the second sermon for the morning
the questions being the first
genesis 13 reading from verse 14
the lord said unto abram after that lot
was separated from him
lift up now thine eyes and look from the
place with our
northward and southward and eastward and
westward for all the land which thou
seest to thee
will i give it unto thy seed to thee
and to thy seed
that's what god promised him verse 17 he
said arise
walk through the land in the length of
it and in the breath of it for i will
give it unto thee
so the promise was that god would make
abraham a large nation but a nation
needs to live somewhere
and the promise included a land that
would belong to abraham
and that would belong to his seed
look at chapter 15 of genesis reading
verse 5
as we continue a better day is coming
genesis 15 reading verse 7 the bible
says
and he said unto him i am the lord that
brought thee out of her of the chaldees
to give thee this land to do what to
inherit it
abram was supposed to inherit the land
of canaan
let's go to hebrews chapter 11.
hebrews chapter 11 are there any if you
have an empty seat next to you could you
raise your hand
an empty seat next to you those of you
standing if you don't mind taking the
weight off your feet
you see some up raised hands there's
some empty seats here oh by the way i
forgot after the questions i was
supposed to advertise these books
at the end of the service i will make
sure those who do not have a great
controversy
that you get one next to the bible
always have this book
next to the bible always have this book
the last day of restoration i am still
begging for amen some people just don't
learn
and that's me where were we
hebrews 11 reading from verse 8.
by faith abraham when he was called to
go out into a land
which he would have to receive for an
inheritance obeyed
he knew he would receive it and he went
out
not knowing whether he went he sojourned
in the land of promise
as in a strange country
in tabernacles with isaac and jacob the
heirs with him
of the same promise meaning what god
promised
abraham he promised isaac when isaac
passed off the scene
he promised jacob the three
premier patriarchs that's why god is
called the god of abraham
isaac and jacob
for he looked for a city which have
foundations
whose builder and maker is what
is who god let me put two verses
together
verse nine and ten
he sojourned in the land of promise
what does the word sojourn mean to dwell
for how long
temporary temporary your sojourner
when abraham looked for a grave to bury
sarah
genesis 23 don't go to genesis 23 verse
4 he said
i am a stranger and a sojourner with you
i really don't belong
he sojourned in the land that was
promised to him
now that's hard it's hard
it's like a mother who just delivered a
baby but is critically ill and it's an
icu
and she's two inches from the baby but
that two inches of two inch glass
she can't touch it
he's sojourn in the land of promise as
in a strange
country dwelling
in what tabernacles
with isaac and jacob the heirs with him
of the same promise
now in verse 9 he is dwelling in
tabernacles look at verse 10
while he is dwelling in tabernacles
for he looked for a city which hath what
foundations whose builder
and maker is god now
verse 9 he's dwelling in a tabernacle
verse 10 he's looking for what
does a tabernacle have foundations
what's a tabernacle a tent
does a tent have a foundation or do they
have pegs what do you do with the pegs
pull them up and move on
stick them in the earth pull them up
move on abraham
dwelt in tabernacles but while dwelling
in the tabernacle
where was his heart they've had what
foundations what does foundation
represent
permanence stability yes all of those
are fine but i was looking for
permanence
permanence i am not moving anymore
let me ask you a question at a three
after twelve don't answer me
are we dwelling in tabernacles
now it's mental
or are we living in such a way that
someone looking at us will say
this man intends to be here for a long
time
our institutions tabernacles
are our churches tabernacles
is there a sense of temporariness if i
may say that about all that we do
the plans we've laid for the future for
our children
for our retirement do they bear the
color
of a tabernacle
where is our mind
on that city the bible has a
tremendously powerful
psychological principle that allows us
to take any distress
while we live in tabernacles that is put
your mind on the city
as long as your mind is on the city
the experiences of the tabernacle are
bearable
he looked he desired
a city which hath
foundations that foundation of course is
christ
whose builder and maker is god
except the lord build the house finish
it for me
they labor how in vain that building
through faith also verse 11 sarah
herself
received strength to conceive seed and
was delivered of a child when she was
past
age because she judged him faithful who
had promised
therefore sprying there even as one of
one and him as good as dead
so many as the stars of the sky in
number
and as the sand which is by the seashore
innumerable meaning the offspring from
isaac
verse 13 these all died
not having received the promises
now god told abram as much to his face
as he could
i will give you this land you
but the bible says abraham isaac
jacob sarah rebecca rachel
these all died not
having received the promises but having
seen them
afar off
and were persuaded of them and embraced
them
and confessed
that they were what strangers and
pilgrims on the earth now
they had a confession of faith
by everything they did and how they
lived
the surrounding nations knew they were
different people
they confessed the most effective
confession is not what you say
but how i live
question number two don't answer me
reflect on your life i'll reflect on
mine the plans we've made
that which brings us joy satisfaction
happiness
does that give a profession that we
embrace the promise of that new city
that's coming
what is our profession as given off
by our lifestyles
examine our ambitions in the light of
this verse what
profession does our ambitions do our
ambitions give
off
we need to understand that god can't do
certain things in the world we do
certain things
it's always been god's plan as a
corporation of heaven and earth for the
carrying out of certain plans
they confessed there were strangers and
pilgrims on the earth now verse 14 of
hebrews 11
for they that say such things what are
the such things
that they're pilgrims at strangers and
pilgrims they that say
that not verbally by their lives declare
what's the next word
plainly that they do what seek a country
question number three don't answer me
does the city of loma linda receive a
plain declaration from us that we're
headed elsewhere
don't answer let's narrow it
do my neighbors in my neighborhood have
a clear message from my lifestyle
that i am headed to another country
we need to understand that many people
will be saved not by a crusade
or tent effort but by the influence of
our lives
not all people are saved the same way
some are saved just by one-to-one
influence
for they that say such things hebrews 11
14 declare
plainly no confusion that they seek a
country
verse 15 and truly
if they had been mindful
of that country from whence they came
out they might have had
opportunity to have what returned
do we understand what paul is telling us
in this verse
and truly if they had been mindful
when abram left irv the chaldeas genesis
12.
and of course isaac was born in canaan
so was jacob
but they knew about earth the caldes we
believe in studying our genealogy
we believe in tracing our roots all
people love that
oral history requires that we know what
came from the past
yet the bible says and truly if they had
been mindful
if they had been thinking of the life
they left if they had been pioneering
for a lifestyle they left
they could have gone back
many people leave the church because
they never really left the world
they pined for the life they left
we're in the church and waiting for the
sun to set to go back to that party that
i used to enjoy
and you we sit and we're suffering
because we're so
withdrawal symptoms we miss the world
and we tend to find those things that we
miss
abraham who is our spiritual father
put it out of his mind
verse 16 but now they desire
a better country that is a what a
heavenly
wherefore god is not ashamed to be
called their god god is not ashamed
to say i am the god who of that people
that live
in tabernacles i am the god of that man
who by his lifestyle makes it clear
i don't belong here i am the god of that
institution that conducts this business
in a way that says we are temporary
i am not ashamed to say i am a god of
people who live temporary lives
and for those of us who live as though
we belong here is is he ashamed to be
called our god
yes
for he hath prepared for them a city
i said based on verse 13 abraham
sarah isaac rebecca
rachel jacob
they died now numbers 23 19 tells us
very plainly
you know the verse god is not a man
that he should lie did god lie to
abraham
no did abraham received a promise
is it that abraham received a promise
did he receive it
we have an associate preacher in the
audience not yet and he's right
did he receive it in his lifetime no
did god lie no but we have a problem
the man didn't get it he never lived in
it when his wife died he had to buy some
land to bury his wife
because he possessed none read acts
chapter 7 verse 4 and 5 where stephen
said he gave him not one
foot of land
not a square foot abraham received yet
he had the promise
go back to genesis 13.
look at verse 14. it's 12 minutes after
12.
genesis chapter 13 the chapter in which
love left abraham or left abram
his name changed in genesis 17 5. so in
chapter 13 12
15 16 his abram not abraham because the
name has a different meaning
verse 14 and the lord said unto abram
after that lot was separated from him
lift up now thine eyes and look from the
place with our art
northward and southward and eastward and
westward
those are the four directions of what
of what the world
so where's god telling abraham to look
all over the world
and the bible bears that out i'll take
you in a minute now
abraham may not at that moment have
realized
the tremendous scope of god's words to
him
but since we read in galatians 3 8 and
the scripture foreseeing that god would
justify the heathen through faith
preached beforehand the gospel unto
abram saying and in thee shall all
nations of the earth be blessed
god was explaining to abram the gospel
and he understood it because jesus said
in john
8 58 your father abram rejoiced to see
my day and he saw it
and was glad so when god said in genesis
13 14
lift up mouth and eyes and look from the
place with our northward southward
eastward westward
for all the land which thou seest to
thee will i give it
and to thy seed god was promising abram
how much the whole world
literally i said literally
that abraham would inherit the whole
world let's go to romans
4. as we continue a better day is coming
romans chapter 4.
reading verse 13.
romans chapter 4 reading verse 13
the bible says and the promise that he
should be the heir of
canaan are you
sure you see world
and the promise that he should be the
heir of the world was not to abram and
to receive by the law but by the
righteousness of faith
when god told abraham that he would give
him this land to inherit
it god meant ultimately yes
at a physical level the israelites did
come in and occupy that land
under the judges under solomon under
david
and the rehoboam until in 1721 the
assyrians took them out
and then in 586 the babylonians took
them out
so physically they did but they
inherited it but never carried out the
reason why
it was given to them
so god was thinking further afield god
was giving abraham
physical land for a spiritual reason
which would then cultivate cultiva uh
culminate
in a literal inheritance here's what i
mean
god promised him physical land and the
12 tribes did come in from the
wilderness
they occupied it physically but a
spiritual lesson was
that they should live in that land as if
that land was a small heaven
you understand me so surrounding nations
can see
what a heavenly lifestyle is like and
come then when jesus returned
he would put them now in the true canaan
which is this world made new
question number four don't answer me
when you give physical things to your
children what is the spiritual lesson
when you give them a hundred dollars to
buy a video game what is the spiritual
lesson
for that child
you don't give them anything but give
them some food please we can't be that
harsh
give them some clothes but this is
serious business
there must be some spiritual
significance
attached or children don't grow
nor do adults
and so god promised abram the world
the whole world but where is abraham
in the grave can god lie
no will abraham get what god promised
how far will god go to keep his word
he will raise up a man from the dead
come on praise the lord louder than that
god will
god is so determined to keep his word
that if you
die before he has a chance to give you
what he promised
he will raise you from the dead
to keep his word and we know that the
lord himself
shall descend from heaven with a shout
with the voice of the archangel
and with the trump of god and abraham
shall rise first
[Music]
you can say amen he's one of the dead in
christ
we must apply the scriptures personally
abraham shall rise first
then we which are alive and remain
god has to come back
and keep his promise to abraham
because in hebrews 11 13 tells us these
all died
not having received and god says my word
shall not return unto me void
so the universe is watching that's what
he said
the man is dead what will he do
and he said his word cannot return unto
him void he does not lie
abraham is dead
abraham represents whom the faithful
he also represents god in another sense
he represents the faithful that's why in
galatians 3 29 we're told
if he be christ then are ye abraham's
seed
and heirs according to the promise
which means that none of abraham's seed
has yet received the full promise
we haven't but is god
eager to keep his word yes
yes what's holding him up
it's a two-letter word try
two-letter word try us give me the
subjective form
we
us as someone's doing something to me no
we're doing it and we
partnering with pardon the grammar we
are fully
responsible for the delay in the return
of jesus christ to keep a promise
to the man who heads the list of those
of whom god says
i am the god of abraham isaac
and jacob
adventists know from scripture
despite what some differently bent
adventists will tell you
prophecy says that christ could not have
come
before 1844.
all historic adventists say amen he
couldn't have come
because he the god of prophecy had
outlined
the history of the world something had
to happen
at a certain time in the midst of the
week the messiah had to be cut off
80 31. three and a half years later
something else happened
1844 something else happened and that is
the last
event attached to a prophetic timeline
october 22 1844 now if you're not
adventist and this sounds odd and
strange and bewildering
get into an adventist bible study group
and they will show you
from scripture that the history of the
world
is laid out to those who study scripture
through the eye of faith
and trust in the spirit now after
1844 jesus could have come
at any time
how many years has it been since 1844
let me tell you something adventists
love to say how will we get the message
to the buddhists
how will we get the message to them
the muslims how will we get the message
to those who practice taoism how will we
get the message to those who practice
shintoism how will we get the message to
this person that person you know that's
not god's problem
at pentecost acts chapter 2
there were assembled men from all
nations under heaven the elamites the
the those from mesopotamia all kinds of
land
they were assembled and some early
adventists could have said back then
how will god get the message to all
these languages
that wasn't god's problem god provided
languages the tower of babel
you know what god problem has been from
genesis to revelation
he cannot get us to commit ourselves
100 percent to his agenda for the
universe
we from history past
have been god's source of his divine
ulcer
his people
so we spend a lot of time developing
strategies for winning people to christ
and we send people to seminars how to
reach the post-modern mind
as if the postmodern mind has a
different nature from the from the
pre-modern mind
and we have departments dedicated to
reaching the hindu and reaching
which i suppose is fine as it is
what god does not need is more
strategies what god needs is more
commitment
how much tragedy did peter have on the
day of pentecost how much that
john and the other disciples have they
had one thing they put away the
differences
and the work of god became first and god
came down with the strategy
which is the holy spirit
you see if you focus on strategy it
takes the spotlight of me and my
commitment
we don't baptize because the strategy is
not working you know the sinful nature
we have
is very creative it finds ways to remove
the spotlight from offline
strategies well the folks in the
himalayas they live too far
can't reach them people in the amazonian
jungle
it's too dense we need to build roads
we do everything except focus on the
fact
that god's problem is as i said
we pardon the grammar
jesus when he was on this earth was a
prophet
12 24. i got a note saying i could
preach to 12 45.
since i hear no man should i say the
benediction
all right okay all right
he was a prophet what is he now
a priest what is he long to come as
king now i've told you many times god is
the god of what
order procedure one thing always comes
before another
the order for the life of christ was you
go as a prophet in human flesh
and speak for me god who in sundry times
and diverse manners spake unto the
fathers by the prophets have in these
last days spoken with us by his son he
was a prophet for the father
the clearest expression of god's will
jesus christ
we have some high priest which cannot be
touched we have not such a high priest
which cannot be touched with the feeling
of our infirmities hebrews 4 15
he is now high priest
but he's coming back as what king of
kings
lord of lords he could not
begin his priestly ministry until what
he had finished
i said he's a god of order one thing
after the other and i listed the three
for you we have one right person
he could not finish he could not start
his priestly ministry
until he had finished what his earthly
prophetic ministry
god bless you he cannot
begin his kingly reign
until what he ends
his priestly function
what is the purpose of a priest
to make atonement make reconciliation
for the sins
of the people hebrews 2 17
that is what christ
is stuck and i use that word very
respectfully
he is stuck
in the most holy place offering
atonement offering forgiveness
forgiveness forgiveness
much forgiveness presupposes what
much sin
now i thank god for forgiveness don't
get me wrong
but god forgives us and puts us on the
path to experience what
victory
i was talking to one of the departments
here yesterday i think
and one nice man said i thank god for
forgiveness
well you can't argue with that so i told
him how about thanking god for some
victory
you know what forgiveness means where's
the cameraman i'm going to move
so i hope you're athletic this is my
housemate dr curtis farm let the church
say amen
nice man business-like forgiveness
is like this you're walking
your sin that's a sin
that's a sin that's a sin that's a sin
lord i'm sorry lord i'm sorry
lord i'm sorry you can make a cd lord
i'm sorry lord i'm sorry
lord i'm sorry now jesus didn't die just
to provide that
because that is progress on a flat plain
here's what victory does thought i'm
sorry
lord i'm sorry that's ten years between
the two
that is progress on a plane that goes
up too many of us
we like the flat plane
we've got a sin twitch that's all we
have and we sin
and we sin and we sin and jesus says yes
i came to provide forgiveness
but i also have victory as demonstrated
in my life
don't you want some of that you know we
have this saying you know do you want
some of this
and jesus says you want some of this we
must say yes
i want some of this jesus says here's
all you can get
are we not tired of sin
so as long as we're sending up sin
jesus is stuck
and there are people suffering in darfur
and it's the fault of adventists don't
say anything
it's adventist's fault that jesus hasn't
come
not the muslims stop beating up on them
it's our fault there's a civil war in
the angola
um democratic republic of the congo in
northern uganda where 1.2 million people
are displaced
it's our fault because god called us to
preach a message no one else has
it's a message to prepare for people to
receive christ we don't do it in our
preaching
in our schools and our churches and our
health and nothing do we do it
and so the world is as stuck as jesus is
jesus looks down and he sees people
dying by the thousands from starvation
and he looks around and the adventists
are trying to make the best they can in
this life
jesus looks down and he sees little
children pot bellied with starvation
dying of all sorts of diseases and he
looks around
and he sees our medical institutions
like any other one in the world health
message not helping anyone
jesus looks down and he sees well these
are people with these diseases who are
they okay and
now this is my people what's the problem
we eat like the world
so we suffer like the world
jesus looks down and uh okay
all these broken homes where they coming
from he looks at his people
jesus is stuck
with the crazy glue of our crazy lives
and he can't move
because of our sins
now for us to put jesus out of business
which is what that should be our aim you
see
make god unemployed
make him king take away his work
as priest there's a there's a tournament
in medical school where i used to work
called riff
reduction in force you were rift we
don't need any more priests
we long to hear from heaven let him
which is
filthy be filthy still him that is
unjust be unjust still
let him that is righteous be righteous
still let him that is holy be holy still
and behold i come quickly and my reward
is with me we long to hear that in our
souls
because when we desire victory
and no more sins ascend
jesus will finally put off his priestly
robes
put on his kingly regalia
with that crown that's not jewelry
and come back for us
finally to fulfill his word that he made
to abraham
about 4 000 years
ago
and you and i can help to hasten
the return of jesus christ
there to be no sin in the sanctuary
above
there must be no sin in these centuries
down here
that is why it is so dangerous when
people say
you cannot live without sinning because
if you say you've got to commit a sin
from time to time
jesus is stuck forever
the purpose of the gospel is to
save us from sin
all sin and god will do something i
don't know what he will do but god
will not allow his son to be stuck in
the most holy place
interminably god will rise up
and what he does we will not like
you know when i pray preparation for
sermons or whatever else i do
i say lord i humble myself
because if you do it i may walk with the
limp for the rest of my life
so i humble myself quick
as the lord i lay my glory in the dust
because if you do it
i will suffer
it is better now to do god's work than
to have him create some circumstances
that make life so miserable for us
because otherwise says if we don't do
his work now that there's opportunity
and very no persecution virtually to
speak of in this part of the world at
least
which represents the headquarters of the
work we shall have to do it
in terrible times what's your choice
christ desires to come and usher in that
better day
but he's coming for a church without
spot
or blemish or any such thing in other
words he's coming for a church
that looks like him
when christ sees that we
have made up our minds by his grace
no more sin going up
then he can leave
because we would have made up our minds
to the point where there is no
turning back that's what god wants the
three hebrew boys hananiah mishael and
azariah
they stood in front of that furnace
and has uh negriq and nazar he did that
thing seven
times hotter it could not have been any
hotter
on the surface of the sun
but their decision their purpose of
heart
was even hotter than the heat of the
flames
our determination to be faithful to god
must be greater than the threats to our
lives
that's why the church at smyrna which
received no rebuke
in the message christ sent to that
church revelation 2 10 be
thou faithful unto what death
not just loss of job be thou faithful
unto death
and i will give you a crown of life
christ wants to come back but he's not
coming for a people living in sin
he's not doing it
he's not coming for people disobedient
to his word
he's not coming for people who look like
the world in every area of living
he's coming for a people peculiar and
holy
how many of you will say lord i want to
be one of your special people can i see
your right hand
ah god bless you you have no idea what
does what happens to my heart when you
raise your hand so
genuinely
i have another appeal to make it's uh 12
as you search your heart and i search
mine you can take your hands down now
you've heard the message
if you believe based on the conviction
of the message that
you by the life you have lived and i
by the life i have lived if we can say
by our lives
we have kept christ stuck in that holy
place
and he can't come down we have delayed
his return
because of the way we have lived and you
and i will say in our hearts lord
i am sorry my eyes have been
opened give me the spirit of christ
that i may so live my life that my life
hastens your coming if no more than by
ten seconds
anyone who will say father let me so
live
that my life contributes to the
hastening of the return of christ i want
you to stand up
and i want you to stand not so much with
your feet but with your heart
last night i made an appeal
which i'll repeat today
but first of all i want to ask
there may be someone here who drifted
from god
and has been living in sin and you know
it you're living outside of the will of
god
that has been your lifestyle no one know
but you
and because the holy spirit of god has
touched your heart through this message
and previous messages you've heard
you will say to god openly
you know jesus says if you confess me
before man i'll confess you before my
father
you will say father i know i have
drifted i
know it i don't want details
god knows them better than you but you
will see it today
with spiritual courage like that
prodigal son
coming from that far country i am coming
back
because i believe he will receive me
with open arms i want to come
back clearly this appeal does not appear
to all of you i want to
come back to my savior whom i left
if you will say that you leave your seat
and come and stand right over here
god bless you come
come i can have a little music by the
pianist
i need the every hour
come right up front come sister right up
here right up here
i'm coming back come right up here
this symbolizes full return to christ no
lower level for you in the presence of
god
right where god is i am coming back i
know i have
drifted from god i am coming back
because i believe he'll receive me
as he received the prodigal son coming
back
i neither arrow very quietly very softly
come right over here
god bless you and i mean it from my
heart god bless you
and i don't want to delay this but this
is vital i'm sure you understand
some people only accept christ if they
are invited to do so
and so i must extend the invitation for
a return to christ i hope you understand
do not worry about food we're fasting
someone else come sister god bless you
god bless you
i don't care what your culture is your
culture is not to move i want you to
change culture right now and get up and
come
someone else as the spirit of god
touches your heart
i know i have drifted i know it
lived outside of the will of god
dangerous place to live
it's only by god's mercies we're kept
alive because the devil tries to kill us
all the time
in an unprepared state that when christ
comes we go to hell
he wants to kill us in an unprepared
state it's dangerous to live outside the
will of god
someone else you're drifted and you know
it come
there is no embarrassment in coming to
christ none
that's why he's not ashamed of us he
took our nature come god bless you my
brother
my good sister god bless you
you got a friend that should move take
that person by the hand bring him bring
her
save someone god bless you my good
brother god bless you
god bless you someone else
i know in my heart
i drifted and i mean drifted by the
prodigal son
i know it no one knew it because i still
came to church
they still saw me but i was gone
come loving father in heaven
we bow in your presence in this solemn
moment
not thinking of food of rest of anything
else but
what we are here for and that is the
business of salvation
father too often we play with you
the bible says because judgment to give
an evil work is not speedily executed
therefore the heart of man is set in him
to do evil
father if you struck us the moment we
hurt you
none of us would survive but we take
your mercy for granted
and so we run and we run and we play but
today your sons and your daughters have
come to say
i know i have drifted and i come back
like the prodigal son the prodigal
daughter
because god does not judge he does not
remind us of our past lives
he receives us as if we never left
something we as humans need to learn to
do father receive those who have come
back
standing behind me and around me they
god receive them
and put into their hearts now the
assurance
of that full reception you receive them
the son receives them the holy spirit
receives them
all the angels receive them moses elijah
enoch in heaven receive them
every being in heaven receives them that
is how heaven receives someone who comes
back or who comes for the first time
god father put
into their hearts a determination
to be faithful to you unto death
let them stand before the flames of
temptation
before the furnace of the the pressure
from friends
and determine they will be faithful to
you come what
may that's the kind of people
you want faithful to you their god
for them pleading that you will give
them that heart like jesus he went up
that hill
he fell he got up he stumbled a little
bit he fell he got up because he was
determined
to make it to the top of that hill give
us that kind of mind
that will not give up though we bleed
from every poor
please father hear us answer us
and bless my brothers and sisters
gathered on this stage i pray
in the name of jesus christ and for his
sacred all god's people say
amen last appeal
father as i make this final appeal
give me the words and soften the hearts
that need to respond
in jesus name amen
last night i made an appeal for those
who need to be baptized
or re-baptized because either you were
baptized as a child
didn't know what you were doing you left
god brought the covenant you need to
come back
you remember for religious tradition
that did not preach the truth however
honestly
now you discovered truth you never knew
you're coming to christ in a different
way
you need to be baptized or re-baptized
anyone listening to me or behind me
you are convicted you should make a
decision
to be baptized you really should have
made it last year for the previous
restoration you didn't
of the one before you need to do that
now because that's what jesus wants
if you will make that decision now and i
want you to do it
raise your hand wherever you are god
bless you
god bless you i want you to come come my
good is it my sister brother back there
i just saw a hand
i couldn't tell the gender tell her or
him to come
someone else i am deciding today
to be baptized to make preparations to
be baptized come god bless you
god bless you god bless you become my
sweet sister god bless you
god bless you god bless you god bless
you
god bless you yes i saw that hand some
of them came last night
anyone else i am deciding you can take
your hands down now
i am deciding to be baptized god jesus
wants it
it is a righteousness who else
ever had bowed every eye closed
reverently in the presence of god
father paul said
in acts chapter 20 verse 26
wherefore i take you to record this day
that i am pure from the blood
of all men for i have not shunned to
declare unto you all the
council of god acts 20 26 and 27
father i want to leave loma linda
pure from the blood of all people
i have preached i have called
i have appealed father i am not
satisfied
that all who should have come have come
but even jesus was not 100 successful
and i can't expect to be but lord as i
pray
if your spirit will soften a heart let
that person move even
during the prayer father for those who
raise their hands for baptism
i pray i pray i pray
give them the courage
the courage to stand by their decision
give them the insight the
understanding to know that regardless of
their age
they can be used by you to lead
someone else to the kingdom give them
the certainty father that regardless of
their circumstances
economic or otherwise they can be an
instrument
in your hands an instrument of salvation
to others
lord the devil is angry and will do
whatever he can to discourage
i pray you surround my brothers and
sisters with angels that excel in
strength
that they may stand by this decision
today
oh father we want to place in your
kingdom when you come
we want to be saved and we pray lord
that you would give us the power
grant us the spirit of your son put your
word in our hearts
and a desire to serve you that's
stronger than death
fortify us against the attacks of the
world i pray
immunize us if you can if you will
against the infection of worldliness
give us a heart and a love for jesus
that only grows
every day now father as we disperse
let us do so with the consciousness we
are your people
and this is your day and bring us back
later today at 4 for the healing service
i pray
in jesus name and for his sake amen
you